Willkommen an der
Militärakademie in Wiener Neustadt.
Ich bin Oberst Markus Reisner.
Ich bin der Leiter der Forschungs- und
Entwicklungsabteilung.
Und heute wollen wir uns in einem neuen
Video den Sachstand betreffend der
Lieferung von schweren Waffen
in die Ukraine ansehen.
Das erste, das wichtig ist zu verstehen
ist, dass, wenn Streitkräfte erfolgreich
einen Konflikt bestehen wollen, müssen sie
über verschiedene Fähigkeiten verfügen.
Diese Fähigkeiten kann man
in Teilbereiche unterteilen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier an Beispielen drei
heraus: Einerseits die Fähigkeit zur
Führung, die Fähigkeit, effektiv
Aufklärung zu betreiben, aber natürlich
auch die Fähigkeit zum Angriff.
Nur wenn all diese Fähigkeiten erfüllt
sind, können sie den Konflikt
für sich entscheiden.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, werden
sie diesen Konflikt verlieren.
Wenn wir uns nun die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte ansehen, so sehen wir, dass
all diese Fähigkeiten in den einzelnen
Teilstreitkräften abgebildet sind.
Heute wollen wir uns im Speziellen
die Landstreitkräfte ansehen und das, was
an Gerät dort verfügbar ist bzw. ob dieses
Gerät zusätzlich durch die
Waffenlieferungen entsprechend
verstärkt werden konnte.
Die ukrainischen Landstreitkräfte
befinden sich über die gesamte Ukraine
verteilt, natürlich mit Schwergewicht
dort, wo die Kämpfe stattfinden,
also im Raum Donbass,
bei Charkiw,
aber natürlich auch hier, entlang dieser
langen Frontlinie von Cherson bis Saporischschja.
Wenn wir uns das Gerät ansehen, das
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte am
24. Februar verfügbar hatten,
so können wir anhand von drei Beispielen
sehen, dass die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
sehr potent aufgestellt waren.
Sie verfügten über knapp 2.400 Panzer und
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge,
über 1.500 Artilleriegeschütze und Mörser
und über 500 Mehrfach-Raketenwerfer.
Diese einzelnen Gerätschaften waren
gegliedert in verschiedenen Brigaden.
Die Brigaden sind quasi die Kernelemente
des Gefechts, mit dem Die Ukraine versucht
nun den russischen Angriff abzuwehren.
Diese Brigaden kann man wie folgt
ansprechen: Die Ukraine verfügt über
Gebirgsbrigaden,
motorisierte Brigaden, mechanisierte Brigaden,
Panzerbrigaden,
aber auch Artilleriebrigaden.
Am Beispiel der Panzerbrigaden
sehen wir, dass die Ukraine am
24. Februar zwei aktive Panzerbrigaden hatte und
vier in Reserve sowie ein
selbstständiges Panzerbataillon.
Damit diese Brigaden ihre Fähigkeiten
entwickeln können, brauchen sie
Unterstützung,
die wir hier links und rechts sehen.
Hier ist zu betonen, dass diese
Unterstützungskräfte sehr wesentlich
sind, zum Beispiel hier am
Beispiel der Fliegerabwehr.
Nur durch effektive Flugabwehr ist es
möglich, dass diese Brigaden tatsächlich
ihre Fähigkeiten entwickeln können.
In dem knapp drei Monaten andauernden
Konflikt wissen wir, dass im Wesentlichen
drei Bereiche dazu beigetragen haben, dass
sich die ukrainischen Streitkräfte so lange
gegen die russische
Seite zur Wehr setzen konnten.
Das eine war die Taktik, vor allem in
den ersten sechs Wochen des Konflikts.
Das zweite war die Lieferung von Waffen,
vor allem von Panzerabwehrwaffen,
aber auch Flugabwehrlenkwaffen.
Und das dritte war natürlich die
Übermittlung von Aufklärungsdaten.
Diese drei Bereiche haben dazu
beigetragen, dass wesentliche Fähigkeiten
gestärkt werden konnten, wie zum
Beispiel die Führungsfähigkeit.
Der Bereich der Aufklärung,
aber auch die Angriffsfähigkeit.
Heute wollen wir uns nun ansehen, ob die
Lieferung von schweren Waffen bis jetzt
bereits dazu beigetragen hat,
dass die ukrainischen Landstreitkräfte
sich in ihrer Fähigkeit
verbessert haben oder nicht.
Dazu sehen wir uns als erstes an für den
Bereich "Engage"- also Angriffsfähigkeit,
die Lieferung von Kampfpanzern.
Bis jetzt war es möglich, in die Ukraine
knapp 100 Kampfpanzer zu liefern,
aus Tschechien, aus Polen, aber auch
eine gewisse Anzahl aus Bulgarien.
Alle Systeme vom Typ T-72, also Systeme,
mit denen die ukrainischen
Soldaten vertraut sind.
Diese 100 Fahrzeuge bilden im Kern eine
verminderte Panzerbrigade, also
knapp zwei Panzerbataillone.
Schauen wir uns an die Lieferung
von Kampfschützenpanzern oder
gepanzerten Transportfahrzeugen.
Auch hier ist es so, dass Tschechien,
Polen, die Niederlande,
aber auch Litauen Fahrzeuge geliefert
haben, zusammengerechnet
ebenfalls knapp über 100 Stück,
was die Ausstattung von zwei Bataillonen
in einer verminderten
Brigade darstellen würde.
Kommen wir nun zur Artillerie, deren
Bedeutung in den letzten Wochen
besonders hervorgehoben worden ist.
Hier müssen wir unterscheiden zwischen
gezogenen Geschützen und Lafetten.
Bei den gezogenen Geschützen
haben Estland und Bulgarien Systeme
geliefert, noch aus der
Zeit des Kalten Krieges.
Italien hat ebenfalls bereits Systeme
vom Kaliber 155 Millimeter geliefert.
Bedeutungsvoll war aber natürlich die
Lieferung des Systems M777
durch Australien, die USA und Kanada.
Insgesamt circa 140 Systeme, was auch hier
die Ausstattung einer verminderten
Artilleriebrigade darstellen würde.
Sehen wir uns nun die Selbstfahrlafetten an.
Auch hier wissen wir, dass Polen
und Norwegen M-109-Derivate geliefert haben.
Auf der anderen Seite Tschechien
Systeme vom Typ Dana, aber auch
alte Systeme vom Typ 2S1.
Signifikant war die Lieferung von zwölf
Stück Caesar der
französischen Streitkräfte.
Das ist jenes System, das bis jetzt
das potenteste am Gefechtsfeld ist.
Und auch hier ist der große Vorteil, dass
das Geschütz in der Lage ist, die
russischen Streitkräfte über
eine hohe Distanz zu treffen.
Und dazu zeigen wir Ihnen
ein kurzes Video.
Wie stellt sich die Situation bei
den Mehrfachraketenwerfern dar?
Das Waffensystem, das auch sehr intensiv
in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen diskutiert worden ist.
Hier ist die Situation
tatsächlich sehr trist.
Wir haben eine Lieferung von knapp 20
Stück eines tschechischen Systems vom Typ
RM-70 sowie ebenfalls knapp
20 Stück vom Typ BM-21.
Beide Systeme verschießen Munition
sowjetischer Provenienz noch aus
der Zeit des Kalten Krieges.
Wir haben die Ankündigung der
Lieferung von Mehrfachraketen-
Werfersystemen: Das System HIMARS, aber
auch das System MLRS. Wenn man
die Stückzahlen betrachtet, nämlich vier
Stück, die aus den USA kommen sollen
bzw. sieben, die aus Deutschland
und aus Großbritannien kommen,
Stellt sich die Frage, ob diese geringe
Stückzahl tatsächlich den erhofften Effekt
auf dem Gefechtsfeld bewirkt oder nicht.
Warum ist die Artillerie nun so wichtig?
Der wesentliche Hintergrund ist, dass
beide Seiten versuchen sich zu bekämpfen
außerhalb der Reichweite der
Geschütze der anderen Seite.
Man erkennt hier sehr gut, dass erste
Lieferungen von Systemen aus dem Westen, wie
diese Panzerhaubitzen 2000, die Mitte Juni
geliefert werden sollen, aber auch des
französischen Systems Caesar,
das sich bereits im Einsatz befindet,
es den Ukrainern möglich ist, außerhalb
der Reichweite der russischen
Geschütze wirksam zu werden.
Noch viel effektiver stellt sich dies dar
bei der Lieferung von Mehrfach-
Raketenwerfersystemen,
wo die russische Seite vor allem durch das
System "Smertsch" mit 70 Kilometern im
Moment einen großen Vorteil hat.
Und natürlich ist zu betrachten: die
massive Überlegenheit
der russischen Artillerie gegenüber
der ukrainischen Artillerie, wie es hier
in diesem Kommentar der Washington Post
zum Ausdruck kommt.
Wenn wir uns jetzt die aktuellen
Forderungen der ukrainischen Seite
ansehen, so sehen wir hier in diesem
Twitter-Kommentar eines
Regierungsberaters vom
13. Juni 2022,
dass die ukrainische Seite massiv
Unterstützung mit schweren Waffen fordert,
nämlich über 1.000 Geschütze
- gezogen oder auch auf Selbstfahrlafette - über
300 Mehrfachraketenwerfer, über 500
Kampfpanzer und über 2.000 Schützenpanzer
oder gepanzerte Transportfahrzeuge.
Wenn wir also vergleichen: Das, was
bereits geliefert worden ist,
im Gegensatz zur Forderung, dann sehen wir,
wie groß sich die Ablage tatsächlich darstellt.
Wichtig ist zu verstehen, dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte
vor zwei Dilemmata stehen:
Das erste Dilemma besteht darin, dass die
russische Seite seit dem 24. Februar
laufend in Luftangriffen die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte abnutzt.
Selbst der ukrainische Präsident Selenskyj
geht davon aus, dass bis jetzt über 2.600
Marschflugkörper, aber auch ballistische
taktische Raketen, die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte zunehmend abgenützt haben.
Das heißt, das Problem ist, dass dieses
Arsenal an Marschflugkörpern und
taktischen Raketen entsprechend
bekämpft werden muss.
Das heißt, die bis jetzt durchgeführten
Waffenlieferungen haben zwar dazu geführt,
dass die Bereiche Führungsfähigkeit,
Aufklärung, aber auch Angriffsfähigkeit
gestärkt worden sind.
Aber wesentliche andere Fähigkeiten, wie
zum Beispiel der Bereich Schutz,
die wurden nicht gestärkt, was dazu führt,
dass diese Abnützung der ukrainischen
Seite durch die russischen
Luftangriffe laufend passiert.
Um das vermeiden zu können, würde man
benötigen: Den Einsatz von potenten
Fliegerabwehrsystemen wie zum Beispiel vom
System S300, wo wir hier
kurz ein Video zeigen.
Die Herausforderung besteht darin,
dass zwar die gelieferten westlichen
Waffensysteme in den Einsatz gebracht
werden können, dort aber von den
russischen Streitkräften aufgeklärt und
angegriffen werden können,
wie man das zum Beispiel hier erkennt.
Am Beispiel einer M777-Batterie,
die offensichtlich durch die russische
Seite erfolgreich bekämpft worden ist.
Die zweite Herausforderung besteht darin,
dass die angelieferten Waffensysteme in
die Hände der russischen
Streitkräfte fallen können.
Dass dies der Fall ist, das wissen wir
bereits durch die Lieferung der leichten
Panzerabwehrwaffen oder Fliegerabwehr-
Lenkwaffen, wo die russische Seite nicht
wenige davon erbeuten konnte und nun
selbst gegen die
ukrainische Seite einsetzt.
Auch dazu ein kurzes Video, in dem man
erkennen kann, dass erbeutete
Waffensysteme von den russischen
Streitkräften eingesetzt werden.
Das zweite große Dilemma,
das für die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
besteht, ist die Frage:
Was soll mit den hereinkommenden
Waffensystemen getan werden?
Soll zusammengewartet werden und es
zu einem geschlossenen Einsatz kommen?
Oder sollen diese Systeme sukzessive
an die Front gebracht werden
und dort eingesetzt werden?
Die Wichtigkeit dieser Frage wird einem
bewusst, wenn man die Stückzahl der
angelieferten Systeme betrachtet.
Von der deutschen Panzerhaubitzen 2000
sollen bis Ende Juni zwischen sieben
und elf Stück geliefert werden.
Selbst von Systemen alter Bauart wie diese
tschechische 2S1 wurden
knapp 20 Stück geliefert.
Die Frage ist, wartet man zusammen und
setzt diese Systeme geschlossen ein oder
schickt sie, so wie sie
kommen, direkt an die Front?
Um die Herausforderung der Anlieferung der
schweren Waffensysteme besser zu erklären,
habe ich hier noch zwei
Skizzen vorbereitet.
Die erste Skizze soll Ihnen zeigen:
Die konkrete Frage, ob nach der
Anlieferung der Waffensysteme
diese zuerst bereitgestellt werden sollen,
in der Tiefe der Front, also zum Beispiel
hier im Raum Cherson oder hier im Raum
bei Charkiw oder Donbass,
und ob nach einem Bereitstellen und
Zusammenführen der Kräfte es zu einem
geschlossenen, massiven
Einsatz kommen soll.
Im Moment sieht es danach aus, dass die
angelieferten Waffensysteme
stückweise in den Einsatz gehen, direkt an
die Front, womit sich die Frage stellt,
ob sie dort ihre tatsächliche
Wirkung entfalten können.
Das heißt: Wäre es nicht schlauer, ein
Brigade-Äquivalent zusammenzufassen und
dann anzugreifen oder so, wie es jetzt
passiert, die Elemente, die hereinkommen,
Stück für Stück quasi an
die Front zu verlegen?
Ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist der von den
ukrainischen Streitkräften
durchgeführte Angriff bei Cherson.
Hier war es der Fall, dass eine
mechanisierte Kampfgruppe versucht hat,
gegen die russischen Streitkräfte
vorzugehen, jedoch in weiterer Folge
eingekesselt und zerschlagen worden ist.
Auch hier ein kurzes Video, das den
Einsatz dieser ukrainischen
Kampfgruppe zeigt.
Wir wissen also, dass die Lieferung von
Waffensystemen, vor allem von schweren
Waffensystemen, angelaufen ist.
Wie man das hier erkennen kann, haben fast
alle europäischen Staaten
begonnen, Systeme zu liefern.
Und die Frage, die sich stellt, ist, ob
diese Lieferungen rechtzeitig kommen bzw.
ob sie auch richtig eingesetzt werden.
Zum Schluss möchte ich Ihnen mit diesem
Bild zeigen, dass die Lieferung von
schweren Waffensystemen
eine ganze Reihe von zusätzlichen
Herausforderungen mit sich bringt.
Dazu gehören nicht nur das Anliefern der
Waffen, geschützt gegen zum Beispiel
russische Luftangriffe,
oder auch die Frage sollen sie Stück für
Stück in den Einsatz
gehen oder geschlossen.
Sondern es stellt sich vor
allem die Frage der Ausbildung.
Hier in diesem Bild sehen wir
die Ausbildung von ukrainischen
Artilleristen am gelieferten
norwegischen M-109-System.
Zusätzlich zur Ausbildung und zur Qualität
der Ausbildung ist auch die Frage zu
stellen, ob die richtige Munition
verfügbar ist und auch in der richtigen
Anzahl, um die Herausforderungen der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte im Osten
entsprechend bewerkstelligen zu können.
Damit beende ich meinen Vortrag.
Ich sage herzlichen Dank fürs
Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.